[MUSIC PLAYING]
CLEMENTINE JACOBY:
Welcome to the session
on real-world gaming.
So my name is Clementine Jacoby,
and I'm a product manager
on Google Maps.
I'm actually based out
of Sydney, Australia
which is where Google Maps
was born 13 years ago.
But today, I'm
going to be talking
about real-world gaming.
So first, I'm going to start
with a little bit of history.
For those of you who
know Maps really well,
you can just take
a quick power nap.
But after that,
I'll show you some
of how mobile developers are
using location data to create
immersive experiences,
and then I'll
dive into how you can get
started building games
with real-world data.
So let's dive in.
Google Maps has been
building and understanding
and expanding a
deep understanding
of the world since 2004.
And since 2005,
we've been making
pieces of that model available
to developers like you.
In fact, the Maps API was one
of Google's first APIs ever.
So over the last 13 years,
our model of the world
has evolved from providing
static maps to dynamic maps
to then location intelligence.
For those of you who saw
Gayathri's keynote yesterday,
location intelligence
means delivering
a rich, relevant,
realtime context
about the world around the user.
And through location
intelligence,
developers are bringing
elements of the real world
into their applications.
At the same time, they're
bringing their applications
into the real world by
augmenting the world
around their users
with digital content.
As the augmented reality,
or AR, revolution
begins to take shape,
we at Google Maps
are seeing information,
imagery, and animations
for mobile services
superimposed on the real world.
Developers can now
annotate real-world media
to help people find places
faster or make informed
decisions or just have fun.
AR is enabled by two key trends.
The first one is that super
powerful mobile devices
are becoming more and more
prevalent and integrated
into daily life.
The second is that
advancing technology, things
like location
precision, now allows
us to place digital objects
in our real environment
with increasing accuracy.
So this goal of informing and
orienting and delighting users
at a glance is now closer
than it's ever been.
So how did we get here?
The first thing is a good model.
So over the last 13 years, we've
improved our model of the world
by adding, again, more digital,
dynamic, and realtime content.
The second piece is
better technology.
In those 13 years that we've
spent improving our model,
technology has
also gotten better.
And over time, combining
this accurate model
with improving technology
has opened up new use cases
for real-world information.
This has led to
really big changes
in how maps are
displayed and used.
So let's look at
this progression.
For hundreds of years, we
used paper maps to navigate.
And then just 20 years
ago, AJAX brought maps
to the digital world.
This enabled the first-ever
Google Maps product,
a map that could be explored
in your web browser.
We designed our first
directions offering
to help these desktop users plan
their journeys ahead of time.
But then the mobile era ushered
in this huge paradigm shift
for maps.
So suddenly, users
were out walking around
with their phones,
and they expected
us to tell them where to go.
They needed more than
just digital maps,
they needed dynamic
maps that adjusted
as they moved through the world
with their smartphone in hand.
So as mobile took center
stage and adoption rates grew,
demand shifted away
from route planning,
and demand for on-the-go
navigation surged.
As users came to rely
on us for directions,
they did so even when they
were driving or biking,
so we had to adapt our
offering to determine the best
path no matter how
you were traveling.
To do this, we
needed to learn way,
way more about
real-world dynamics.
Like how is the traffic?
Were there accidents
along the route?
What were the public
transit schedules?
And we made all of this
dynamic information
available via our
Directions API so
that it could be used by
third party applications.
Drivers were then able to use
that Directions API to optimize
their routes around
passenger demand.
And as location data
became more precise,
ride sharing apps
started to flourish.
Then with the advent of big
data and machine learning,
we were able to move
again from dynamic maps
to realtime location data.
We now take an ever increasing
number of these realtime
signals into account to provide
our users and a huge range
of third party applications with
a more nuanced and intelligent
model of the world.
For example, rich
and reliable data
coupled with powerful
machine learning algorithms
allow us to help drivers
route around realtime traffic.
And as of recently--
and I think this one is
very cool for everyone
who's from San Francisco--
with the help of
machine learning,
we can let you know if it
will be difficult to park
at your destination right now.
So as mentioned,
the canvas for all
of this realtime information
is our model of the world.
Advancing technology has enabled
us to go beyond the digital
to dynamic to
realtime information.
Meanwhile, that underlying
model of the world
has become more
sophisticated, and it can now
supply these realtime
services with all the detail
that a developer
or our algorithms
need to make
intelligent suggestions.
So let's look at how that
underlying model has evolved
to support new use cases.
Our very first product,
that web-based digital map,
used 2D imagery.
We expanded on that
product and included things
like 3D buildings and
elevation models and terrain.
And then to usher
in the mobile era,
we turned our
attention to helping
users navigate urban
environments while on the go.
Places play a really
big role here.
Understanding cities is sort of
an obsession for Google Maps.
Our maps now surface tons of
detail about real-world places
to help users orient
themselves, but also to explore.
So one of my favorite Google
Maps products is the Corridor.
When I'm in a new city, I like
to know that one block over
from me there are tons
of shops and restaurants,
and I'm happy to walk a
block or two out of my way
to go down a street
that's hopping,
And Corridors let you do that.
Our Places API is
this amazing resource
that makes details like this--
about 100 million points of
interest across the globe--
available to developers.
And just like our
other services,
the Places API is
constantly bringing
in more and more dynamic and
realtime information sources--
things like business' open
hours and ratings and reviews.
And then finally, it turns out
that a lot of users like me get
lost indoors, especially.
So today, Google
Maps can even help
you explore inside of
places like shopping malls
and airports.
This is a perfect
example, by the way,
of advancing technology, like
indoor GPS and an improved
model of the world like
indoor maps combining
to create a new use case
for maps in the wild.
OK, let's look at
one more example
of a user experience where
I think our underlying data
model really shines--
going out to dinner.
So today, Google Maps can help
you find a restaurant based
on its location, ratings,
and reviews, read the menu,
check how busy it will be now
and later tonight, book a table
and hail a ride, all
from Google Maps.
And to make this
possible, we had
to bring together many
different signals about movement
in the real world, including
how cars, trains, and crowds are
moving.
So this is what
it looks like when
you bring this all together.
At the bottom,
you've got technology
steadily marching along,
improving and raising
the bar for developers.
And then riding
that wave, you have
this increasingly
sophisticated model
of the world with
more and more realtime
information about the
global environment.
And when we put them together,
new possibilities emerge.
Services that ingest
this model become
more relevant and intelligent.
And critically,
those same services
could be what power
your next game.
So how are developers
like you using
this model of the world
in your applications?
Well, at Google, we're
seeing a big shift in demand
from dynamic mapping solutions
like directions and place
search to location intelligence.
What is location intelligence?
So it goes beyond the map.
Location intelligence is
about bringing together
everything we know about
the world around the user,
about the context
around the user,
and then delivering insights
when they're useful.
Location intelligence,
for example,
allows us to go beyond
knowing that there's
a bus stop near you to knowing
the timetable for that bus stop
to knowing how close the
next bus actually is.
Or it means not just
telling you that there's
a taco shop a block
away, but actually going
a step further to tell you
that the tacos are cheap
because we know you like cheap,
and that the shop is open now,
and that it's not
even that crowded,
and that the reviews
are fantastic.
Understanding your users'
constantly changing environment
is key to building experiences
that are relevant and personal.
Personally, any taco
near me is to taco
that I want to know about,
but that level of detail
might be annoying or
bizarre or just irrelevant
for someone else.
So location intelligence--
it's powerful for developers
because it allows you to
build relevant and rich
experiences that cut across
industries, and in some cases
even create new ones.
For example, ride sharing.
Not long ago, we stood on
street corners and hailed cabs.
No location
intelligence involved.
But now, we request a car
that arrives in moments.
It's chosen based on
its proximity to you.
And as it arrives,
we watch its approach
in our app in real time.
Your driver shows up
already knowing your desired
destination, and all of
this is context specific
to an individual user.
This is location
intelligence at work.
It's an experience,
and in this case,
it's a whole industry
that just couldn't have
existed without location data.
I promise I'm getting to gaming.
So in other cases, we
see location intelligence
enhancing existing
industries, apps, or services.
Mobile services
leverage location data
to build experiences that
aren't really about maps,
but they're tied to or fueled
by or mixed with the real world.
One simple but very
powerful example of this
is the check-in.
So in basic terms,
what is the check-in?
It's just a way of recording
a real-world action.
But the applications of the
check-in have proven expansive.
You can check-in to let your
friends know where you are,
you can check-in to get
a deal at a real store,
or even check-in
to enter a contest
or rise on a leaderboard.
And actually, the
leaderboard piece
is interesting because
it demonstrates
that a simple use
of location data
is also a way of turning an
everyday action into a game--
a game you might win by
rising on a leaderboard
or getting from point
A to point B quickly
or unlocking a special treasure
at an obscure location.
So what we've noticed at Maps
is that integrating a location
into your mobile service
often turns that experience
into a game.
Look at exercise.
Exercise has proven itself
ripe for gamification.
Tons of developers
are using location
to augment their apps
and services in exercise.
Today, you can use apps
to track your workouts,
compete with friends,
log miles, earn trophies.
Top brands are using location
data to gamify exercise.
Points and milestones
and competitions
are helping users get fit,
clear hurdles, stay motivated.
And critically,
as developers use
gamification to help
users achieve their goals,
users respond by spending
more time in the app.
So gamification
leads to engagement.
In our API business,
we see brands competing
to make their apps more
involving and immersive
and compelling by bringing
in more and more location
intelligence.
They're using
location to motivate
and to encourage competition
and to engage their users.
And as that happens, the
very definition of a game
has already begun to blur.
Lots of real-world
experiences lend themselves
well to gamification,
and I'm sure you've all
seen it in your industries.
We definitely have.
Exploring a city is
kind of like a quest
where you have to unlock certain
skills to achieve milestones.
Finding a good meal is
always an adventure.
So is trying to navigate
traffic with insider
tips based on
realtime traffic jams.
But these are all
implicit games,
and what we're
starting to see now
is that developers are making
these game-like aspects
explicit.
So we've talked
about two trends,
and they're unfolding,
really, in parallel.
First, as I illustrated
earlier, as devices improve
and our model of
the world becomes
more nuanced and
precise, developers
are suddenly able to augment
the world with digital content
in ways that just
weren't possible before.
And secondly, as
powerful devices
become more and more
integrated into life,
standards for what constitutes
an engaging mobile experience
just keep rising.
This is causing a shift
that's bringing routine tasks
and fun closer together
through gamification,
and game developers find
themselves right at the nexus
point of these two trends.
And boy are game developers
rising to the occasion.
So let's look at an example of
a developer, a game developer,
using location data, powerful
smartphone penetration,
and innovative
technology to create
a phenomenon that would not have
been possible a few years ago.
Last year, we saw real-world
gaming go mainstream overnight.
On July 5th, a company named
Niantic launched Pokemon Go,
and by the morning of July
6th, people of all ages
were outside walking around,
collecting virtual Pokemon.
This game was different from
any that had come before,
and you could see
it on the streets.
But real-world gaming
is not a new idea.
We've been building games
based on real-world discovery
for a long time.
Think of geocaching or scavenger
hunts or Niantic's first game
that they built within
Google, Ingress.
But the difference now
is that mobile phones
are advanced enough
and ubiquitous enough
that real-world games have
a massive potential market
with all of the
technology that they
need to play in their pockets.
The difference now is that
our model of the world
is so detailed that it can be
used to build experiences that
leverage this complexity
and dynamism in ways
that weren't possible before.
So we're arriving
in a place where
it's possible to augment the
world with mobile content
and to augment
mobile experiences
with real-world
content, and this just
raises the bar, again, for what
highly engaged users will soon
demand.
The colossal growth
of Pokemon Go
confirmed that we've arrived
at an inflection point--
a time when a sophisticated
model of the real world
combined with powerful IP and
an unprecedented game mechanic
can be leveraged by smartphones
to blend mobile experiences
with the real world.
The launch of Pokemon Go
was a global phenomenon
not only for its unique
gaming experience,
but also because of
its explosive growth.
Niantic and engineers
from Google Cloud
worked together to scale
to 50 times Niantic's
forecasted traffic
to accommodate
their unexpected
popularity at launch.
Niantic set out to
create a different kind
of gaming experience, as well--
one that got participants
off of their couch
and into the real world.
They leveraged Google
Maps, among other sources,
to create a truly iconic
augmented reality game.
So let's take a
closer look at some
of the technologies
and data that
are used by real-world games.
This is not specific
to any particular game,
and the details
will vary depending
on what you're trying to build.
But at a high level,
these are some
of the features you'll need.
First, precise user location.
Location precision has
improved dramatically
in the last couple of
years, and it continues to.
It's now possible to tell not
just what city block you're on,
but what store
you're in front of,
and even what you're looking
at, or what direction
you're facing.
And for developers, this means a
more fine-grained understanding
of exactly where their users are
in relation to in-game objects.
Real-world games can
leverage recent improvements
in location
precision to pinpoint
exactly where its players
are and, in some cases, what
they're looking at.
Next, base maps.
To build a real-world
game, you need a map
that reflects the real world.
You need the geometry that
defines roads and paths
that users walk along.
You need polygons that define
the building footprints
around them.
You need the outlines of
parks and lakes and fields
and the metadata that helps
you actually distinguish
between those things.
You don't want to place objects
in the middle of a large body
of water because
you thought it was
a park, or style lake the
same way you would style park.
In a real-world game, a style
based map is your game level,
and there are lots of
choices for the developer
and the artist to make.
What level of visual interest
do you want on the map?
Where do you want to focus
your users' attention?
For example, you might use
a full 3D building model
to create an
immersive experience,
or instead, you could use
simple building footprints
to orient users without
overwhelming them
with visual detail.
There are a lot of
ways to use geometry
and the metadata of map
features to determine
how to style a game world.
And you can also use the
base map to design gameplay,
and this is a bit different.
So here, you might use
the type of an area
to determine what
kind of game object
would be collected there.
For example, you could
use a map to determine
where the forests
are, and allow users
to go there to collect wood.
Finally, global scale.
With Google Maps global
rollout of a game
can take place
seamlessly because you
can leverage the infinite
variation of the real world
to make your game
nuanced and interesting
no matter where
it's being played.
So let's focus on
just the maps piece.
How could you use our maps
to create a real-world game?
At a very, very high
level, it looks like this.
First, you request map
tiles from Google Maps.
Then you filter
all the data that
isn't critical to your game.
So for example, maybe you don't
care about road labels or road
shields or cycling lanes because
you expect all your users
to be walking.
Next, you would style
the map to suit the look
and feel of your game.
For example, you could make
pedestrian paths and boardwalks
and beaches really broad
and visually dominant,
and you could de-emphasize
highways and freeways
and other places that you
didn't want to encourage
your users to walk.
You can apply your own
styling to any area
on the map using the underlying
metadata to determine what type
of area it is.
The result is a look and
feel that's all your own.
And finally, you add your game.
The map is just the foundation.
Now you add the characters,
landmarks, and interactions
that drive gameplay.
That's just a
high-level overview,
and now I want to use an example
to dive a bit deeper into how
you can use geodata to build
real-world games, and some
of the considerations
that you'll
encounter as a developer.
So for the purposes
of this exercise,
let's imagine that you want
to build a real-world version
of a resource-gathering game.
So in this game,
players will move
around collecting resources
and claiming land and building
kingdoms and forming
alliances, and so forth.
The variations on this
theme are infinite,
and it lends itself well to a
location-based gaming example
because there's lots
of different types
of real-world data that
you'll want to consider
when you're building it.
One of the very first
things you'll want to do
is link valuable resources--
things like iron
and wood and water--
onto real-world locations
like restaurants and schools
and grocery stores.
To do this, you
need to understand
what types of businesses are
within reachable distance
of the user.
You'll also need to know
properties of the businesses
in a given area.
For example, maybe
you want to identify
all of the real-world banks
and allow your players
to collect in-game currency
at those locations.
Or maybe you want to map
a rare type of business
to a rare resource.
Maybe some treasures are so
special that they can only
be collected at a single
landmark per city,
and others are much more common,
like collecting provisions
at a grocery store.
Maybe some resources
move around like herds
of animals and others are
fixed in static locations.
Let's say you've done
that, and after linking
real-world locations
to in-game resources,
you turn your attention
to understanding
how your game is
driving foot traffic,
and how much foot
traffic it's driving.
You'll want to know
where crowds will be so
that you can generate more
resources in crowded areas.
Otherwise the resources
will dry up quickly
and your game will be no fun.
Your players can't progress.
You'll want to understand how
player behavior downtown is
different from player
behavior in the suburbs.
And if your game is
played all over the world,
you'll probably
need Cloud Analytics
to find these patterns--
how the game is being played
at night versus in the day,
and rain versus shine,
or even in the northern
versus the southern hemisphere.
All of these things make a
difference to your players.
Once you find these
patterns, though, you
can adjust your
game accordingly.
For example, in Sydney
where the weather's perfect,
it makes sense to place
resources in parks.
But in New York City
during the winter,
you probably want to place
resources in subway stations.
Then with a better understanding
of how your game drives
foot traffic, you could consider
how to thoughtfully connect
your players to the
world around them,
including the businesses
restaurants, and shops
around them.
Some businesses will be
super eager to connect
with your players,
and they'll want
to be featured as coal mines or
collection points in your game.
But other businesses,
like hospitals,
won't appreciate crowds
near their entrances.
To address this, you need
a centralized catalog
of the businesses
around your users--
all of them, all over the world.
Pairing that with a
good understanding
of player behavior will
enable you to evolve gameplay
in a way that responds to
the player's environment
and results in a game
that's fun for them
and also fun for the
businesses around them.
Again, this is the essence
of location intelligence--
contextual signals about
the user's environment
are used to enhance
their experience.
OK, now let's talk
about the map itself--
the best part-- the
land, water, roads,
and buildings that form the
foundation of your game.
In this case, the world
is your game of level,
and the burden is on
you, the developer,
to understand it in enough
detail to create a good game.
If you accidentally
place a valuable object
in the middle of an
industrial-scale garbage dump,
someone is going to
find a way to get to it.
Creating a game that's
both achievable and fun
means knowing where you're
incentivizing players to go--
again, at global scale.
You'll need to understand
properties of the regions
that each player is in.
In the urban
environment, you can
use a unique building
facade or building shape
to orient a user.
In the suburbs, you might use
parks, and in rural areas,
you'll need to use terrain
and trails and paths
to orient them.
How do you design a single game
that's exciting everywhere,
no matter where
your players are?
In urban areas, you might use
3D building models or mark
entrances to large businesses
or display indoor maps.
And remember, all of this
needs to be performant enough
to display on a smartphone.
How should geography
influence your game?
Should items perched atop a
hill or hidden in a dense forest
be worth more than items placed
at a busy convenience store?
What about weather?
Should players who
venture out in the rain
get more points
than those who live
in the always-sunny Sydney?
Probably.
What about mode of travel?
Should resource hunters
on public transit
get more points than
resource hunters in cars?
Or should the points
be player-specific?
Like should you get more
points for exploring
the world, further
away from your home
or while you're on vacation or
more than 100 miles from where
you work?
Those were all static
features of the map,
but, of course,
you'll probably want
to make your game more
engaging by incorporating
real-time elements, as well.
And the possibilities
here are really endless,
but I'll just illustrate a few.
So for example,
as day transitions
tonight, maybe the look and
feel of our game will shift.
Maybe the game's night
mode incentivizes
a totally different
set of behaviors,
when most shops are closed,
some streets are deserted,
and people are congregating
around a few central points
of interest.
What about real-time events?
You could attach special
temporary resources
to a parade or a game
or another event.
What kind of events are there?
A concert.
This is a way to make your game
more social and more integrated
with daily life.
And, of course, you'll also
want to avoid sending users
to businesses that are
closed and down streets that
are deserted, and you
need real-time data
to do both of those things.
You'll also encounter lots
of interesting challenges
when you deploy this
game in the wild.
Users will try to
spoof their locations.
They'll pretend to be in many
places at once and collect all
possible resources, amassing
giant fortunes and building
castles that cannot
be surpassed,
and just ruining the
game for other players.
You need to detect cheating and
prevent it at a global scale.
You need to place treasures
carefully, and make sure
that you aren't incentivizing
players to traipse
into private property.
You might also want to help
players avoid busy traffic
and understand where it's safe,
appropriate, and even ideal
to play games without having to
verify each location manually.
I hope that example helped
highlight some of the ways
that geodata, including location
intelligence, real-time data,
and the map itself
can be used to design
a next-generation
real-world game.
Even this pretty
simple and very generic
example illustrates that
there are endless ways
to use geodata to make your game
safer, more social, and more
immersive.
And by the way, I think lots
of these apply to services
outside of gaming, as well.
All mobile developers are
pretty interested in making
their services safer, more
social, and more immersive,
and we think that
Google Maps data
can help you do that at scale.
When you design
around the world,
you get an experience that's
unique and nuanced no matter
where your users are, and
that's really powerful.
And, of course, when you
deploy this in the wild,
you need Cloud
Analytics to inform
gameplay and Cloud
Infrastructure
to support global rollouts.
We're gearing up to see many
more real-world games released
this year.
Game developers are
beginning to approach
us to understand
how they can conduct
the real world to
gameplay, and how
they can use location
intelligence to build
more immersive experiences.
We think Google Maps is
well-positioned to power
that connection,
and we want to help.
As games get more
sophisticated, we'll
see them leverage real-world
data in new and inventive ways,
including all of the
things I just talked about.
Those things will then
become table stakes
for the games that follow.
We're excited to see developers
use the new technologies that I
touched on.
Location precision and powerful
smartphones are here to stay,
and we're thrilled to see
developers combine them
with the new and emerging types
of geodata that we can offer.
So we want to work
with game experts
to discover new
frontiers in this space.
If you have ideas that combine
base maps with dynamic place
information in your game or
application, come talk to us.
We want to help developers
leverage metadata
about the base map to understand
their players' environment
or connect players to the
businesses around them
or provide 3D models to
help them orient themselves.
If you want to use aggregated
movement data or other location
intelligence signals to drive
engagement, then let us know.
We want to help
developers understand
how their players are
moving in the world,
and how their game is
ultimately being played.
We also want to hear
your ideas about how
to use data to stop
cheaters, and build
fraud detection into your
games before you launch.
If you have special
requirements around analytics
and infrastructure,
definitely let us know.
We're here to help
developers analyze
player behavior to improve
the in-game experience.
We can help crunch data
and deliver insights that
improve your game in real time.
We don't want you to have to
think about your infrastructure
scaling, certainly, and we
want to see global rollouts
taking place seamlessly
without downtime or anxiety.
Finally, this one
gets its own slide
because I think it's
really important.
For a real-world game to go
viral, it has to go global,
and our phenomenal
coverage makes
that possible without
manual data collection.
We can provide 3D building
coverage all over the world.
Our Places dataset has
details on 100 million places
all across the world.
What if your game could
be played anywhere,
without spending hours of
developers' time collecting
and stitching together datasets?
Believe us-- we know how
long that piece takes.
Google Maps has been
working for over a decade
to provide a comprehensive
model of the world
with increasingly
dynamic information,
and we're excited to see
how developers will combine
the resources we provide
to make the next generation
of real-world games.
At Google Maps, we're
constantly working
to make our model of the world
more useful to developers.
13 years ago, we started with
a simple web interface that
could be panned and zoomed.
Today, we help developers
all over the world
create experiences
that connect users
to our increasingly
detailed model
of the world in real time.
We've already seen
mobile maps revolutionize
industries like exercise
and ride sharing
and the constant
hunt for good food.
We're seeing more and
more mobile apps use
location intelligence to draw
users in and keep them engaged.
We're also seeing the
real world augment apps,
and apps augment the real world.
And as that happens,
the line is blurring
between an immersive
mobile app and a game.
We're excited by these
early examples that
point to a paradigm
shift in gaming, as well,
and we can't wait to see what
new innovations game designers
will bring to the industry.
We're sure the game
developers will use data
in ways that make
us rethink what
we need to know
about the real world
to create a
compelling experience.
So in summary, if
you're building
a game that incorporates
elements of geodata,
come talk to us and tell us
what you're trying to do.
If you're building immersive
mobile experiences that
incorporate real-world elements,
come talk to us, as well.
And if you see applications
of next-generation geodata
for your business outside
of gaming, come talk to us.
My team and I will be at the
Maps experts area today and all
of tomorrow--
immediately following this
talk and also tomorrow--
and I'm also going to invite
a few of my team members
up to the side of
the stage right now
to answer any questions
that you may have,
so feel free to come forward.
Thank you for your time,
and we hope to talk to you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]